يشرح لنا محمود مراد الان اهميه جسر القرم
الاستراتيجيه نعم مريم الى بؤره الصراع
مجددا يعود اذا جسر القرم بعد الهجوم
الاحدث الذي استهدف ذلك المنفذ البري
الاهم لشبه جزيره القرم مع روسيا افتتحه
الرئيس بوتين شخصيا في مايوير عام 2018
بعد ثلاث سنوات من العمل وكلفه بلغت سبعه
مليار دولار يبلغ طول الجسر 19 كيلو مترا
ويمتد من شبه جزيره القرم الى مقاطعه
كريسندار جنوب غربيه روسيا بني الجسر
بطابقين متوازيين الاول للسيارات وفيه
مسارات والثاني للسكك الحديديه بمسار واحد
وله دور استراتيجي في نقل البضائع والسلع
وحتى امدادات المياه العذبه والطاقه
الكهربائيه زود الجسر بكاميرات مراقبه
تعمل على مدار الساعه وعملت وعملت روسيا
على تحصينه بوضع منظومات دفاع جوي وقطع
عسكريه قربه مضيق كرش